if you lie by various cryptocurrencies
they're not they're not got a mobile
point then I'm gonna be a bunch of
rabbits sitting here in front of us then
they're just gonna sit there the
internet was a decentralization of a lot
of things but it was still a centralized
place which is why you've seen big
companies built on it blockchain goes to
a totally open place I think it brings
reputation and who you are and brand to
a whole new level
I'm not buying Bitcoin I don't know
anything about Bitcoin man you want to
give me some Bitcoin I'll take it but
I'm not buying bitcoins
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference now I started the
cryptocurrency series because a lot of
entrepreneurs have been writing in
saying I want to get in the
cryptocurrencies but they're not
educated enough so that's the aim of
this series to give you different
perspectives on what people like gary
vaynerchuck mark Cuba and Warren Buffett
and others think about cryptocurrencies
to help you make the best decision for
you so today we're gonna talk about
Bitcoin is it only a collectible also if
you want to know what Warren Buffett
Lloyd Blankfein and Gary Vaynerchuk have
to say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next two hundred and fifty four days
for free I will send you a 30 second to
five minute video to help you build your
confidence check out the link in the
description below you will move in the
direction of the people that you
associate with so I it's important to
associate with people that are better
than yourself and actually the most
important decision many of you may not
all of you will be the spouse you're
choosing and you really you want to
associate with people who are the kind
of person you'd like to be who is an
entrepreneur where everything is a
smooth ride and you go through these
things and I'll tell you and you get
criticized and you have to have a thick
skin yeah on a bigger macro
patience and failure they all ladder up
to one thing which is insecurity the
reason people don't put themselves in a
position to fail the reason people
aren't patient is they value other
people's opinions too much okay let's
kick it off with rule number one invest
in productive assets with Warren Buffett
at one point this weekend you said that
Bitcoin and this was basically you were
asked Charlie said bitcoins like rat
poison you were asked about that comment
and you said well it's probably more
like rat poison squared what is it about
Bitcoin that gets you guys so fired up
well when you buy a farm you look at the
crop every year and and what prices are
and you decide whether it was
satisfactory invest by I mean you look
to the asset itself and what it produces
for you when we buy a business we look
at what the business burns and decide
how we feel about it in terms of what we
paid but we are buying something that at
the end of the period we not only have
what we bought in the first place but we
have something that the asset produced
and when you buy non-productive assets
all you're counting on is whether the
next person is going to pay you more
because they're even more excited about
another next person coming along but the
asset itself is creating nothing one of
the interesting things for example is
gold if you go back to the time of
Christ and you look at how many hours
we'll have we had to give up in order to
buy an ounce of gold and you take it
forward to now you'll find the compound
right maybe a tenth or two-tenths of one
percent you know and and and then you
have to ensure during that time but make
sure you know somebody doesn't steal it
from you know everything but it doesn't
produce anything and productive assets
you may have didn't pay too much for a
productive asset but I've bought a farm
in the 1980s and and every year look at
how much you lose the way of soybeans in
corn and at the end of that period I've
still got the farm and I've got some
significant income off of it partment
house operating business but if if you I
by various cryptocurrencies they're not
there I got a mobile plant that I'm
gonna be a bunch of rabbits
in front list and they're just gonna sit
there and I got a hope next time you get
more excited after I bought it from you
and then yeah I'll get more excited by
it from you and actually we could we
could set in the house by ourselves and
we could keep running up fries potatoes
but at the end of the time there's one
Bitcoin sitting there now we got to find
somebody else and and they come to an
end
I made those yeah I mean that's a
greater fool theory that's what you're
saying well it's it's it's buying
something because you expect the pool of
people who want to buy it because they
want to sell it to somebody else will
grow and and and it's wonderful because
it does create a rising price does
create more buyers and people think I've
got to get in on this and and it's
better if they don't understand it
that's the other thing about
non-productive you don't understand it
you get much more excited than if you
understand it I mean if you buy a bond
associates gonna pay you four percent a
year you're not gonna get any pleasant
surprises and she's going to pay a four
percent here but if you you can have
anything you want to imagine if you just
look at something say that's magic you
can do it with shark's teeth there's
seashells or or anything and you know
they did it with tulips and listen 17th
century in and and and Amsterdam and and
and they'll do it again
I mean people they like to speculate
they like to gamble and if you can get
something maybe that has something half
possible going on if you had bought gold
in 1942 and said we might lose the war
we might have to run off to some other
country and you know so let's put our
assets in gold you would have less than
a penny for every dollar you got from
owning stocks less than a penny now
somebody calls out a store of value I
mean I think they're delusionary rule
number two keep a close eye on it with
Gary Vaynerchuk you were an early
investor in Bitcoin right yeah I good
homework yeah
nothing crazy don't keep let's not get
excited here but I did buy some Bitcoin
in 2014 so I was curious about crypto I
bought some aetherium I made some bucks
but I didn't put in real money so it's
nothing that you know I'm not gonna buy
the jet just yet
maybe the Steelers it's a joke a good
friend of mine has worked with me for
five years lives out here just walking
he's a stealer Spencer just for
everybody fun ring yes I thought
cryptocurrency was gonna be real and
twenties do bullish on it I'm
unbelievably bullish on blockchain
technology yeah I I don't know if
Bitcoin or some of the other coins are
going to be the currency that wins but
this would be like somebody saying to me
do you believe in the Internet
yes do you believe in Ask Jeeves maybe
do you believe in Netscape Navigator
maybe do you believe in Google maybe so
the winners on top of blockchain is a
little murky the you know obviously
bitcoins out and about but I'm bullish
on blockchain honestly yeah they say
blockchain has ramifications that can
you know across all sectors really just
change the game you know kind of
open-source it yeah it is a game you
know the internet was a decentralization
of a lot of things but it was still a
centralized place which is why we've
seen big companies built on it
blockchain goes to a totally in place I
think it brings reputation and who you
are and brand to a whole new level and
so I'm very excited to see how it plays
out over the next two to three decades
rule number three have an open mind with
lloyd blankfein
people have here have asked about crypto
currencies does that become a real issue
or not are you worried about them you've
put your toe in the water I worry you
know I'm not really in any kind of
systemic way the people you know it's
you you know it'd be very painful to
somebody who put his or her and try and
networth into crypto currencies but it's
not a systemic issue at this point
people are passionate forward passionate
against it I remember when they came out
first with Islam when they came out with
cell phones
I remember thinking God who the hell is
gonna lug this thing around yeah and I'm
saying and besides there's a [ __ ]
there's ten phone booths on every corner
I'm not gonna cap this is this is a fan
nobody's gonna carry a cellphone so I
just passed on that whole thing turns
out to have worked so now they have
cryptocurrency and you know I always
thought I can't say why it should work
but if it did work I'd be able to
explain it in hindsight why it did
because that has been your secret to
success yeah well you have to look at
things from both sides and say if it
sometimes in a risk thing I say will
this happen what are the chances of it
happened and sometimes I find it easier
to think about something okay let me
postulate this did happen tell me why it
did and I find that sometimes they use a
way of seeing and I look at the
evolution of money and I say you know
you start out with gold as money and
people only take hard currency and you
make gold coins and a gold coin was like
five dollars that had five dollars of
gold and eventually they would give you
a piece of paper with the promise that
there was five dollars in gold to back
the five dollars piece of paper and you
could go in and redeem it then they gave
you a piece of paper and said there's
five dollars of gold but you can't
redeem it and at some point they give
you a paper and says it's worth five
dollars we're not going to redeem it we
don't even have the five dollars even if
you wanted to and we're still doing that
today and I see that morphing and I'm
saying that if you could go through that
morphing if you could go through that
fiat currency where they say this is
worth what it's worth because I the
government says it is why couldn't you
have a consensus currency and so it's
not for me I don't do it I own no
Bitcoin there goldman sachs as far as i
know unless nobody told me has no
Bitcoin but if it does work out I could
give you the historical pathway that
could happen have happened and so I'm
not in the school of saying gee because
it's uncomfortable with me because it's
unfamiliar this can't happen that's too
arrogance and rule number four the last
home before a very special bonus clip is
invest in what you know
with Grant Cardone what do you feel is
the like your top three safest
investments real estate real estate okay
you know why because when I buy a
building with an address it fits in the
right location it will be here 20 years
from now so I had a guy called me about
car dealerships Odessa did I don't want
about car dealerships I know you know if
they're gonna be here so I'm not buying
Bitcoin I don't know anything about
Bitcoin man you want to give me some
Bitcoin I'll take it but I'm not buying
Bitcoin cuz I know I'm not buying
Twitter stock I don't know anything
about toy store they're gonna be here in
the future I don't know I know I only
invest in things that I know will be
there in the future
excluding my condo I'm not gonna buy
that I don't I don't need that I want to
buy things that people pay for
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Mark Cuban on his thoughts on
whether you should invest into
cryptocurrencies or not that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that I
want to know what do you guys think are
you in on the cryptocurrency game do you
think it's a smart investment or not let
me hear it give your thoughts down in
the comments below thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon and enjoy the bonus
clip
I hate gold gold is a religion there's
ABS there's some some fundamental value
to gold but everything else it's it's a
collectible I see gold and Bitcoin as
being the same thing well hate is a
strong word
okay the miners - all of gold the whole
gold spectrum individually is people
I've heard they're great people
but as an investment okay you're right
hate is not strong enough hate with
extreme prejudice as a big coin in gold
on the same level for you what
collectible see okay the value is based
off of supply and demand and the good
news about Bitcoin is there's a finite
supply that will ever be created and the
bad news about gold is they'll keep on
mining more well Goldman Sachs will say
says that we only have 20 years left of
my noble gold well then in 20 years we
could have another conversation
altruistic world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think I'm
saying it's a bloody brief life all of
you have the potential for enormous
success if you want to know what Gary
v-d-j Khalid Oprah and others know about
empire building that most people miss
check out the link in the description
for a free bonus video